في اثناء صدر بالجريده الرسميه التونسيه
قانون الماليه المتعلق بميزانيه سنه
المقبله وتضمن 76 فصلا تشير الى موارد
الميزانيه وتعبئه تموينات الضروريه وترشيد
الجبايه وتداول الاموال الاقدار وتقدر على
الحكومه حجما نفقات الدوله بنحو 54 مليار
دينار علما ان حجم المداخيل المتوقع يبلغ
قرابه 46 مليارا ونصف مليار دينار وهو ما
يجعل تقديرات العجز في الميزانيه تجهز
سبعه مليارات 4700 مليون دينار
الى تحقيق نسبه نمو
81 اجزاء في المئه من المئه في المئه خلال
العام المقبل بينما توقع صندوق النقد
الدولي في تقرير نشره في اكتوبر الماضي
الا تتجاوز نسبه النمو واحدا وسته اعشار
في المياه
والعامه الثانيه على التوالي منذ اجراءات
الخمس والعشرين من يونيو من العام الماضي
التي اتخذها الرئيس قيس سعيد بحل الحكومه
والبرلمان يصدق الرئيس التونسي على قانون
الميزانيه بشكل فردي ودون احالته للنقاش
على مجلس الشعب وهو من فقدته هيئات مدنيه
ومنظمه واحزاب حيث اكد الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل ان اعداد ميزانيه العامه
مقبل تم بطريقه ترسخ سياسه التردد محذرا
من تداعياتنا وصفها بالاجراءات الله شعبيه
والاجتماعيه خصوصا مساله الدعم التي
تضمنتها الميزان
حسره مصادر التمويل الميزانيه في القروض
الخارجيه بالسياسه الخرقاء التي ترحم
البلاد وتغرقها في مزيد من الديون حسب
تعبيره من جهته حضر رئيس حزب افاق تونس
فاضل عبد الكافي من ان البلاد تتجه نحو
الافلاس ونحو كارثه سباعيه واقتصاديه
وكانت هيئه المحامين قد عبرت عن رفضها
لقانون الماليه واكدت انه يعكس حزمه
الالتزامات التي تعاهدت بها الحكومات جهه
صندوق النقد الدولي دون استشاره الفاعلين
الاقتصاديين والاجتماعيه